à notre émission continue évidemment on
explore les défis que l'agriculture
française doit relever on l'a déjà
évoqué mais très rapidement celui de la
souveraineté alimentaire constate cette
équation 67 millions de Français de
moins en moins de recruteurs en France
avec Fabien requin
c'est la viande la plus consommée par
les Français le port selon la filière
ils en mangent en moyenne 32 kg par an
et par personne une consommation
aujourd'hui couverte par la production
made in France mais cette production
enregistre une forte baisse année après
année elle est de l'ordre de 6 à 7% en
2023 elle n'était que de 2% en 2022
parce que le gouvernement avait apporté
un plan d'aide massif fin 2021 début
2022 si on perd la souveraineté on
apportera plus et regardez ce qui s'est
passé pour les énergies demain on nous
reprochera dans 10 ans de d'être
dépendant de certains pays comme le
Brésil ou les conditions de production
ne sont pas les mêmes les producteurs
dénoncent l'accumulation de contraintes
administratives notamment européennes et
la flambée du coût des aliments pas de
quoi inverser cette tendance selon eux
dans certaines filières la France dépend
déjà de ses importations exemple avec
les fruits et légumes seul la moitié de
notre consommation est produite en
France et là aussi la tendance est à la
baisse notamment à cause d'une crise
d'évocation maraîchers et arboriculteurs
sont de moins en moins nombreux
l'objectif que l'on a c'est de
stabiliser cette situation parce qu'on
considère que ce si on ne fait rien avec
le saut général qui se prépare le manque
de perspective on sera à 30 35 % dans 10
ans à la fois pour des questions de
santé publique de sécurité alimentaire
et d'environnement c'est important qu'on
est cette production suffisante sur le
territoire et pour cela la filière mise
en partie sur la recherche et notamment
sur la mutagénèse créée par des
croisements des variétés de fruits et
légumes moins consommatrices en eau et
plus résistante une démarche qui
nécessite une aide financière de l'État
et une vision à long terme comme le
rappelle le patron de la filière céréale
je prends par exemple le sujet de la
création variétale qui est essentielle
pour se passer de plus en plus de la
chimie en agriculture et dans et dans
nos filières et bien la création
variétale demande toujours entre 5 et 8
ans voire 9 ans de travaux
l'autonomie alimentaire du pays en 2030
c'est l'objectif décrété par le chef de
l'État les agriculteurs français en
appel pour cela à plus de
protectionnisme en visite samedi au
salon de l'agriculture Emmanuel Macron a
écarté pour l'instant la signature d'un
accord de libre-échange avec les pays du
Mercosur
et pour débattre autour de ces enjeux de
souveraineté alimentaire Jacques
Géraldine vosner bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste au Point Sébastien
bises bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
directeur du club Demeter chercheur
associé à l'IRIS et auteur de ce livre
la géopolitique du blé publiée aux
éditions
économiques des chambres d'agriculture
France et auteur de la pandémie et
l'agriculture un virus accélérateur de
mutation publiée aux éditions France
agricole évidemment Mathieu croissanto
est resté à mes côtés tiens je vous
propose un sondage pour pour commencer
réalisé par l'Ifop pour la coopération
agricole justement qui nous accueille
ici la question la France a-t-elle les
capacités de production alimentaire
suffisantes pour nourrir ça population
réponse des personnes interrogées 59%
oUI NON à 30% je pose la même question
Géraldine vasner pour commencer est-ce
que la France allait capacités de
production alimentaire suffisante non
elle les a pas
elle les a pas mais c'est assez
surprenant d'ailleurs comme résultat de
son âge c'est que elle les a eus la
France a réussi à être autosuffisante et
puis cette sabesse sa baisse
régulièrement et c'est vrai que ces 10
dernières années les productions se sont
effondrées on importe
60% de nos fruits 40% de nos légumes et
les gens n'en n'ont pas conscience ça
c'est une vision presque un peu ancienne
de notre agriculture
les gens ne réalisent pas la falaise
devant laquelle on se trouve aujourd'hui
et on va justement essayer de détailler
à la fois le constat et puis les
solutions parce que il y en a forcément
Sébastien bis la guerre en Ukraine elle
a rebattu les cartes de de notre
agriculture mondialisée parce que c'est
une réalité est-ce que c'est une
opportunité pour relocaliser certaines
productions ou au contraire c'est c'est
tout sauf le bon moment
je crois que d'abord c'est l'occasion de
constater qu'en France on a une
situation en termes de sécurité
alimentaire et de production agricole
qui est quand même assez remarquable
tout ne va pas bien mais comparativement
à beaucoup d'endroits dans le monde on
est quand même dans une situation
extrêmement privilégiée et je pense
qu'il faut aussi le dire aux
consommateurs et aux citoyens qui nous
écoutent cette guerre en Ukraine elle
rappelle sans doute à l'Europe et à la
France qu'il faut rester fort sur le
plan productif agricole faire un combat
bien sûr sur le climat pour produire de
mieux en mieux mais cette guerre en
Ukraine elle rappelle aussi que
finalement être fort en agriculture ça
peut être facilement des tricoté dans
des pays qui tombent dans une guerre
dans des pays qui tombent dans de
l'instabilité évidemment le système
agricole peut très vite dérailler et
donc la force de l'agriculture française
et européenne c'est peut-être d'être en
capacité de rester extrêmement endurante
depuis un demi-siècle
de prendre la mesure que le monde s'est
transformé qu'il y a de nouvelles
puissances agricoles qu'il y a d'autres
enjeux qui gravitent autour des
questions agricoles et là où je
nuancerais un peu le propos de Géraldine
c'est que bien sûr nous avons
moins de place aujourd'hui sur la scène
internationale et il y a des filières où
on produit moins qu'avant là où on
pourrait produire plus que ce que l'on
fait aujourd'hui mais nous avons
du potentiel et nous avons à nous
souvenir qu'il y a une dimension
économique et géopolitique avec les
questions agricoles et donc c'est
peut-être réintroduire ces variables là
à côté des variables environnementales
sociétales qu'il faut aussi bien sûr
cultiver Thierry pouces évidemment ça se
fait pas d'un claquement de doigts si on
veut relocaliser une production
agricole c'est ça prend du temps c'est
c'est les infrastructures à remettre en
place ou c'est finalement plus facile
que je ne l'imagine quand vous regardez
ce qui s'est passé depuis le début des
années 60 avec la politique agricole
commune dont l'objectif était justement
d'atteindre l'autosuffisance alimentaire
pour les pays fondateurs du marché
commun on y est parvenu au bout d'une
dizaine d'années d'accord donc
relocaliser des productions qui nous
font défaut aujourd'hui
pas toutes
parce que quand vous regardez le calcul
du taux d'auto suffisance du taux d'auto
approvisionnement vous avez les céréales
le sucre les produits laitiers la viande
porcine où on est largement auto
suffisant à tel point qu'on exporte donc
c'est quoi à l'inverse les produits sur
lesquels on a on a perdu des parts de
marché
vous montrez le stand qui est juste en
France non parce que les fruits et
légumes on a des secteurs où on pourrait
être beaucoup plus fort les fruits et
légumes il y a de du redressement
productif à condition de de certaines
paramètres à résoudre et les produits de
la mer c'est notre plus grande
dépendance alimentaire aujourd'hui alors
qu'on est la deuxième puissance maritime
mondiale et parce que sur la mer entre
pêche et aquaculture on a on sait pas
donner les moyens
sur les fruits et légumes par exemple je
suis assez frappé et étonné
de se dire aujourd'hui qu'on n'est pas
autosuffisant ça fait 50 ans qu'on a un
déficit qui est le deuxième déficit
derrière les produits de la mer
justement donc pourquoi
s'interroger aujourd'hui sur le fait
qu'on ne produise pas assez parce que là
si on veut relocaliser les productions
fruitières et légumières alors je mets
un petit peu à part la pomme et la pomme
de terre où on est encore un peu
excédentaire mais ça va nécessiter non
seulement du temps ça va nécessiter des
disponibilités foncières ça va
nécessiter des investissements donc des
moyens financiers on peut aussi
raisonner sur les oléagineux notre
dépendance en protéines végétale pour la
nourriture des animaux elle remonte à
l'origine au début des années 60
lorsqu'on a eu un accord avec les
États-Unis sur l'apport en tourteau de
soja et à chaque fois qu'on a voulu
localiser des productions de protéines
végétales on a été entravé par une
Commission européenne qui disait on ne
va pas accorder des aides à la
production de léagineux Géraldine wesner
on enchaîne malheureusement on enchaîne
de crise la crise covid et la et les
conséquences de la de l'invasion russe
de l'Ukraine est-ce qu'on a commencé à
en tirer les leçons si on remonte là
trois ans en arrière c'est au début de
la crise covid en matière de
souveraineté alimentaire je
je pense qu'on est encore à la croisée
d'un chemin dans les discours oui on
peut penser que la leçon a été tirée on
a pris brusquement conscience que que le
fait d'être dépendant pour notre
alimentation de l'extérieur pouvait
potentiellement nous placer dans les
mains de régime recommandable que ce
n'était pas une situation satisfaisante
pour une pour une démocratie donc oui il
y a cette prise de conscience tout le
monde parle de souveraineté on ne la
voit pas encore se traduire dans les
actes et là je parle au niveau français
comme au niveau européen vous prenez le
plan de la Commission européenne de la
ferme à la fourchette farm to fork
induit des pertes de rendement des
pertes de production qui sont peu
compatibles avec l'augmentation de la
population à la fois européenne et
mondiale et avec cette recherche de
souveraineté et d'autonomie alors ça on
y reviendra évidemment parce que c'est
un enjeu très intéressant passionnant de
ce débat mais Mathieu je voudrais vous
donner la parole pour faire un petit
comparatif parce que là on parle
évidemment beaucoup de la France mais
d'autres pays qui souffrent et peut-être
plus que nous oui mais alors
souvenez-vous hein il y a un an le
Programme alimentaire mondial parlait
d'un ouragan de famine à venir des
spécialistes redoutaient des émeutes de
la fin au moment de de l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie pourquoi au cœur
de leur préoccupations il y avait bien
évidemment l'Afrique et le Moyen-Orient
gros consommateur de blé et l'Ukraine
est un des producteurs majeurs de blé
mais aussi on le sait de maïs de
tournesol de colza un peu moins l'Asie
on était un peu moins inquiet pour
l'Asie puisque l'alimentation de base
repose quand même sur le riz
heureusement cette prédiction
apocalyptique j'ai envie de dire ne sait
pas réaliser ça veut pas dire qu'il y a
rien eu loin de là selon les Nations
Unies on a compté le nombre de personnes
en situation de synchronique qu'augmenté
d'à peu près de 10 millions de personnes
mais sur un peu plus de 800 millions
quant aux gens qui sont vraiment dans un
risque de famine il a augmenté de 20
millions sur un total de 252 millions
les prix ils ont flambé souvenez-vous en
mars dernier en mars ils ont flambé et
puis ils sont un peu retombés depuis
mais je tombais sur un article du Monde
qui recensait les prix il y a quand même
des augmentations de paniers moyen assez
délirantes un plus 700% par rapport à la
moyenne des cinq dernières années où
Soudan par exemple plus 400 % en série +
138 % en Éthiopie alors pourquoi
pourquoi ça c'est pas non plus déroulé
d'abord parce que l'Ukraine a continué
de produire contrairement à ce qu'on
redoutait parce qu'il y a eu des accords
commerciaux le fameux notamment pour la
mer Noire pour permettre d'exporter ce
qu'on pensait qu'il ne pourrait pas être
exporté parce que certains pays du
Moyen-Orient ou du Maghreb on fait face
à une augmentation des prêts
alimentaires certes je pense à l'Algérie
par exemple mais aussi des ressources
supplémentaires parce que les prix du
gaz ont monté dans de dans la foulée
donc voilà il y a pas eu l'Apocalypse
mais il y a eu des pays qui sont quand
même vraiment très très touchés et puis
il y a un risque à venir probablement
parce que c'est la question des engrais
on sait que la Russie la Biélorussie
produisent beaucoup de potasses et que
c'est pas touché par les sanctions mais
ça a du mal à venir et là pour le coup
l'engrais c'est fondamental notamment
pour la culture du riz et si on a du mal
à faire pousser du riz en Asie là ça
risque évidemment de dégénérer Sébastien
bismes vers vous forcément il y a
effectivement une crise potentielle là
sur le sur les engrais oui sur les
engrais la crise en fait elle est
voilà il y a eu la pandémie il y a cette
guerre en Ukraine donc le cours des
engrais a suivi aussi la l'inflation de
l'énergie on sait que les engrais c'est
le temps long agricole donc il y a de
l'inquiétude à savoir quels seront
l'état des récoltes en 2023 dans le
monde ça veut dire du coup des impacts
sur les saisons commerciales encore à
venir et on voit bien que cette guerre
en Ukraine plus le covid avant ont un
effet cascade et géographique et
temporel néanmoins je précise quand même
que si en 2022 tout n'a pas été
apocalyptique il y a quand même 3
milliards de personnes sur la planète
pour qui le sujet premier de
préoccupation c'est de manger donc on
parle de d'insécurité alimentaire grave
pas de l'inflation à 10% pas je ne sais
pas très bien ce que je vais pouvoir
acheter je vais réfléchir etc on parle
une grande partie de la planète qui a
soit fin et n'a rien du tout soit d'une
partie de la planète qui a pas grand
chose pas assez mangé à peu près tout le
temps la même chose donc je pense qu'il
faut pondérer la bonne nouvelle de 2022
sachant qu'il y a plus d'inquiétude sur
2023 parce que la situation est en
Ukraine et à l'échelle du monde est plus
inquiétante aujourd'hui qui a un an donc
moi j'ai plus d'inquiétude pour 2023 que
on a quand même est-ce qu'on peut dire
quand même qu'on a évité le pire en
juillet c'est ça ce je dis ça de mémoire
l'accord sur le corridor est-ce que il a
cet accord a eu des effets positifs oui
ou non alors la bonne nouvelle la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il y a pas eu de
grosses catastrophes climatique dans les
grands pays producteurs exportateurs
d'accord on a évité des mesures trop
protectionnistes même s'il y en a eu
parce que le multilatéralisme a au
minimum fonctionné avec les dispositifs
qui ont été mis en place il y a quelques
années et puis trois il y a eu deux
corridors il y a eu deux corridors il y
a eu un corridor mer Noire qui a permis
à l'Ukraine de maintenir une présence
sur les marchés internationaux sous
égide au New turque avec cet accord qui
est rentré en vigueur au premier août
mais il y a eu un deuxième corridor dont
on doit peut-être parler davantage parce
que c'est ce que l'Europe a mis en place
avec la France notamment qui présidait
le conseil européen au printemps dernier
c'est les corridors de solidarité
terrestres qui ont sorti davantage de
grains du crâne que le corridor de la
mer Noire adapte à date donc je pense
que de temps en temps on peut être fier
de ce qu'on fait en Europe et en France
en terme de solidarité et d'aide pour la
sécurité alimentaire mondiale parce que
c'est tout un dispositif qui a été
développé pour éviter un choc de
commerce pour aider des pays vulnérables
à acheter malgré des flambées de prix et
en libérant des volumes du crâne alors
quelques chiffres sur je reviens à la
France un plus spécifiquement sur notre
auto suffisance l'autosuffisance de
l'agriculture française et le produit
43% de la consommation nationale de
produits agricoles brut et alors si on
rajoute les produits alimentaires
transformés on arrive à 60% en valeur
des aliments nécessaires pour satisfaire
la consommation des habitants français
souveraineté commentaires évidemment à
un objectif affiché par le Président de
la République je vous propose d'écouter
ce que disait sur ce thème le ministre
de l'Agriculture marcéno ce matin sur
notre antenne il y a un certain nombre
de pans de production qui ont perdu en
souveraineté depuis des années pour ne
pas dire des dizaines d'années je pense
aux fruits et légumes je pense à la
volaille je pense à la viande bovine
reconnaissons aussi qu'on est
puissamment exportateur en lait
puissamment exportateur en céréales
puissent spectateur
en vain et spiritueux enfin bref on a
quand même des secteurs sur lequel il y
a de l'excellence mais on a besoin de de
penser notre système y compris avec le
dérèglement climatique y compris avec
les grands dérèglements du monde
géopolitique et économiques en regardant
les facteurs qu'on a de risque qu'on a
sur notre souveraineté notre propre
souveraineté puis globalement les
facteurs de risque qu'on a sur la
souveraineté européenne et mondiale
Géraldine Wessner c'était une promesse
de campagne si je me souviens bien de
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 cette question
de souveraineté alimentaire quel bilan
vous faites
bon il a pas tout à fait réussi à
inverser la tendance puisque les la
balance commerciale agricole si on
extrait les vins et spiritueux elle est
quand même bien dans le rouge 6 milliard
d'euros de déficits en 2021 encore une
fois sans les vins et spiritueux qui
heureusement la tire vers la tire vers
le haut je pense qu'il y a eu une erreur
de de stratégie c'est que ça ne se
décrète pas la souveraineté alimentaire
et l'erreur de stratégie d'Emmanuel
Macron ça a été de prôner une montée en
gamme c'était son discours de Rungis
d'ailleurs en 2017 il l'avait dit bon
finalement on n'arrivera jamais à
concurrencer des productions moins à
meilleure coût notamment d'Europe de
l'Est notamment donc on va on va se
centrer sur la qualité c'était pertinent
pour partie parce qu'effectivement il y
a de la alors ajouter à prendre sur ces
sur ces productions là ça ne n'était pas
en masse c'est-à-dire qu'on a un peu
décroché sur le cœur de gamme et sur le
ce qui fait la majorité de la
consommation on a 68 millions de
Français qui ne peuvent pas se nourrir à
25 ou 40 % plus cher de façon exclusive
et durable donc c'était un peu se
reposer sur les importations et
l'Europe semble prendre un petit peu le
même chemin en se disant on abandonne
toute toute une série de productions
je ne veux pas dire moins 10 ans parce
que c'est pas le cas mais de gamme
moyenne
dont on a pourtant besoin
on va pas manger du poulet Label Rouge
tous les toutes les semaines c'est ou
tous les jours c'est c'est ça finalement
si je dois résumer ce que je viens de
dire Géraldine wesner en trois mots quoi
je vais quand même réagir parce que
allez-y vous êtes là pour ça cette ce
propos tenace qui consiste à dire si on
enlève la viticulture on bascule dans le
rouge en tant qu'economie je vais faire
le raisonnement inversion on enlève les
fruits et légumes vous allez voir qu'on
est très excédentaire donc c'est le
raisonnement ne tient pas la viticulture
est un produit issu de l'agriculture
donc nous nous dit on n'est pas dans le
rouge on est dans le on est dans on est
dans le vert on a eu 11000 dollars en
2022 donc bon et alors sur cette idée de
monter en gamme c'est à dire finalement
pousser les les exploitations qui
produisent du du haut de gamme et
peut-être laisser à d'autres pays la
capacité de produire la moyenne gamme ou
le bas de gamme quand on regarde la
structure de la consommation de poulet
on voit bien chez les ménages chez les
consommateurs que les signes de qualité
sont consommés le week-end ce qui pose
problème sur le prix le prix et le
produit importé et je rappelle que sur
le poulet et la volaille en général
c'est plutôt la Pologne la Belgique
l'Allemagne et les Pays-Bas donc il
faudrait peut-être regarder aussi le
mode de fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne en termes de rivalité
commerciale bon premièrement mais quand
on regarde le débouché principal de ces
importations de poulet c'est l'industrie
de la transformation les cuisiner et
c'est la restauration hors domicile donc
peut-être que plutôt que de convaincre
le consommateur d'acheter des produits
de moyenne ou de haut de gamme tous les
jours on pourrait demander au restaurant
et aux hôtels de faire un effort sur des
achats de poulet
issus de d'exploitation française mais
alors effectivement ça pose la question
Sébastien bise de la cohérence
européenne
c'est est-ce que c'est pas à la
dimension de l'Europe qu'il faudrait
répondre à cette question à la question
de notre débat sur la souveraineté
alimentaire
évidemment il y a une dimension
européenne et on sait qu'aujourd'hui
l'Europe a une politique agricole
concurrentielle la PAC qui est de moins
en moins commune et qui est de plus en
plus climatique donc si on veut rester
arque-booter sur ce cycle pack on peut
le décliner sous différentes formes il
faut d'abord rappeler que la PAC c'est
une politique alimentaire citoyenne
depuis un demi-siècle c'est à dire que
le grand gagnant de la Pâques c'est pas
le producteur agricole c'est le
consommateur européen qui s'est habitué
pendant un demi-siècle à avoir deux toux
de plus en plus sûr de moins en moins
cher
il faut expliquer aujourd'hui que si on
veut être cohérent en Europe sur ces
questions il faut beaucoup plus de
convergence beaucoup plus de règles
uniques et une souveraineté pensée à
l'échelle européenne mais ça veut dire
aussi et donc ça veut dire que la France
doit accepter de ne plus produire
certains voilà ça a toujours été le cas
voilà
un peu plus loin les laisser à ses
voisins quoi je vais même un peu plus
loin on a en France des productions que
les pays européens réclament et ont
besoin bien sûr on inverse aussi à
l'échelle du monde des interdépendants
agricoles et alimentaires à cultiver je
rappelle que quand on consomme des
produits du reste du monde en France
vous rémunérer aussi des producteurs à
l'autre bout de la planète de la même
manière que quand en Asie aux États-Unis
ou au Moyen-Orient il y a des
consommations de produits français dont
on est bien content pour notre balance
commerciale ça fait vivre aussi une
production française donc je pense que
la souveraineté il faut la regarder avec
le sujet de la constance le sujet de la
cohérence mais bien sûr sur quoi on peut
être indépendant sur quoi on est
dépendant et où sont nos
interdépendances si on a pas un
raisonnement avec ces cinq variables là
alors on tombe dans un discours
souveraineté nationaliste avec toute les
glissades politiques que ça peut vous
leur dire alors il y a une question vous
l'avez évoqué vous dites c'est plus la
politique agricole commune c'est la
politique agricole climatique
effectivement ça c'est le programme de
la
fourche de la ferme à la fourchette je
réussis à le dire dans dans l'ordre et
est-ce que ça c'est pour vous c'est
compatible Géraldine wesner avec
l'objectif de souveraineté alimentaire
dont on parle
ça n'est pas la recherche première je le
on n'a pas regardé exactement avant de
de voter ses plans l'impact que cela
aurait sur les rendements sur les
marchés mondiaux effectivement
il y a eu quelques études à la fois du
GRC de d'une université néerlandaise je
crois sur les l'impact de cette
politique alors pour le rappeler
rapidement c'est une c'est 25% des
terres ou 20% des terres en bio c'est
une baisse de l'utilisation d'engrais
une baisse de l'utilisation de
pesticides les études convergent en tout
cas pour dire qu'il y aurait
effectivement des pertes de rendement de
l'ordre 10 à 15%, une hausse de du prix
de l'alimentation de 10 à 15 % aussi et
alors doublement des importations dit
l'université néerlandaise donc ça en
tout cas ça n'a pas été posé clairement
sur la table avant que ces textes soient
votés maintenant on comprend pourquoi
ces textes ont été il y a une demande
sociétale extrêmement forte pour la
préservation de l'environnement le
problème c'est c'est la présence qu'on y
met c'est que dit ce sera
l'environnement d'abord la production
ensuite si ça peut et il me semble que
ça n'est pas forcément la volonté
ni des peuples ni les politiques donc il
y a un moment il faudrait pouvoir mettre
sur cette fonctionner en silo comme ça
pour envisager ces problèmes ensemble
fonctionne pas bien sûr qu'ils peuvent
mais il faudra pondérer un apport
bénéfique un bénéfice risque en fait une
approche qui soit peut-être un peu plus
raisonnable et raisonnée alors je veux
bien vous entendre là-dessus tirez-vous
pour commencer est-ce que c'est
compatible parce que vient de dire
Mathieu c'est est-ce qu'on peut faire
basculer le l'agriculture européenne
vers un modèle on va dire plus
écologique et tenir l'objectif dont on
parle dans ce débat de celui de la
souveraineté alimentaire française non
seulement mais européenne mais depuis la
fin des années 90 avec les réformes de
la PAC on avait déjà amorcé se
basculement vers une agriculture qui
était qui bénéficiait d'aide qui était
conditionné à un certain nombre de
critères environnementaux et là ce qui
est évoqué ici c'est de savoir si la
souveraineté peut se définir à l'échelle
européenne parce que en sciences
politiques on explique que la
souveraineté ne se partage pas sinon on
tombe dans la guerre civile bon et
est-ce que les États membres sont prêts
à consentir
un effort supplémentaire pour transférer
des compétences à l'échelle européenne
de façon à ce que l'Union européenne
puisse définir et appliquer par une
politique adaptée une souveraineté
alimentaire qui va déboucher sur une
autosuffisance et sur la sécurité
alimentaire dans un contexte de guerre
aujourd'hui donc je pense qu'on est là
parce que ce qu'on évoque sur est-ce
qu'on doit privilégier le climat donc la
production on espère pouvoir faire les
deux mais bon on peut faire les deux
mais sauf qu'au passage la pandémie et
la guerre sont arrivés et que ça inverse
probablement ou ça peut amorcer une
autre hiérarchie des priorités dans
l'Union européenne
il y a une invité de notre premier débat
Marion Guillou qui qui disait ben c'est
très bien que l'Europe prenne ce virage
mais si d'autres régions du monde ne le
font pas Sébastien avis il y a là aussi
une distorsion de concurrence et ça
c'est un fin jeu simplifie ces arguments
qui étaient beaucoup plus complexes et
et détailler que ça mais c'est une vraie
réalité est-ce qu'on se tue alors je
vais poser une question là un peu
basique mais est-ce qu'on se est-ce que
l'Europe se tire une balle dans le pied
avec ce programme de de la ferme à la
fourchette bah disons que ce programme
prolongeant une dynamique de
verdissement depuis 30 ans c'est fait
insuffisamment en intégrant les
variables géopolitiques et stratégiques
et allons jusqu'au bout économique
soyons très clair comme l'a dit Thierry
push entre la pandémie et la guerre en
Ukraine il y a un curseur qui se remet
au milieu et qui essaye de remettre à
360 degrés la question agricole
evidemment c'est une question liée à
l'environnement évidemment il faut
demain produire drastiquement mieux et
pas juste un peu mieux on sait qu'on
doit faire des révolutions de production
considérables mais par contre si c'est
pour se retrouver dans 30 ans neutre en
carbone sans être en sécurité en ayant
plus rien de produit et aucun aucun
citoyen satisfait dans son estomac on
n'aura rien gagné donc en fait il y a
deux combats à faire il faut continuer à
pouvoir produire et il faut pouvoir
produire autrement de plus en plus ça
veut dire deux choses ça veut dire que
il y a une vraie responsabilité à ce que
l'Europe soit cohérente dans son action
à l'international cette cohérence ça
veut dire qu'elle doit défendre ses
valeurs il est hors de question que
l'Europe essaie de ressembler aux autres
demain sinon ce n'est plus l'Europe mais
par contre elle doit défendre ses
intérêts et ces dernières années sur la
scène à l'international l'Europe s'est
comporté comme un herbivore dans un
monde de carnivores à la défendue des
valeurs et elle s'est fait désarmer sur
ses intérêts et ses stratégies je suis
peut-être angélique quand vous posez de
questions mais ça peut devenir un
argument de vente c'est-à-dire le fait
d'être la région du monde la plus
vertueuse je mets plein de guillemets
averteuses en matière de production
écologique bah ça va nous attirer des
clients on peut aussi c'est déjà le cas
c'est-à-dire que l'Europe dans le monde
aujourd'hui elle se différencie par
cette production extrêmement durable et
diversifiée mais elle se différencie à
ce niveau là parce que il y a aussi un
contenu proposé et donc des volumes et
donc une qualité qui s'est superposée à
du quantitatif si l'Europe désarme sur
le quantitatif il y aura pas de débat
sur la qualité le reste du monde regarde
l'Europe comme un pôle de stabililité et
en plus qui génère de la confiance qui
honore ses engagements ses contrats qui
a au côté des pays et qu'utilise pas
l'alimentation l'agriculture à la
différence de certains pays à l'Est
comme une arme de guerre et ça je pense
que cette Europe demain plus cohérente
doit être capable de monétiser ça d'un
point de vue stratégique et d'ailleurs
elle serait bien inspirée de regarder ce
que font les Américains les américains
ils ont beaucoup de valeur mais leur
première valeur se défendre leurs
intérêts alors on parle évidemment des
conséquences de cette guerre en Ukraine
l'invasion russe l'inflation elle frappe
aussi durement les agriculteurs et les
agriculteurs en France regardez ces
chiffres en un an les coûts liés à
l'énergie et aux matières premières dans
l'agriculture ont bondit de
16,5% voilà le la stat que je que je
recherchais et toujours sur ce thème
on va donner la parole tiens tout de
suite à un agriculteur de laine il
s'appelle Bruno Cardot il est à 50 ans
donc il y a pratiquement on a pris
pratiquement en euros
sur sur notre lit de de gasoil non
routier qu'on appelle GNR donc pour tout
ce qui est engin agricole avec un
réservoir par exemple sur un tracteur
qui peut faire 500 litres sur une grosse
journée de bout de travail sur du semi
ou du travail du sol on peut vider le
réservoir
Thierry pousse est-ce que cette
inflation elle menace la l'existence
même de certaines exploitations
pendant l'année 2022 cette
alourdissement des charges évidemment
est peser beaucoup mais elle a été
compensée par une flambée des prix
agricoles donc le ciseau des prix a
plutôt été en faveur là d'accord
l'inquiétude qu'on a sur l'année 2023
puisque tout à l'heure vous évoquez
monsieur le fait que les prix baissent
c'est si cette dynamique baissière
s'installe durablement à tel point que
le ciseau va couper le papier et que les
prix vont devenir inférieurs aux charges
qui pourraient rester
constante disons notamment sur l'énergie
parce que la problématique énergétique
reste entière là effectivement ça peut
menacer un certain nombre
d'exploitations qui jusque là était
presque à l'équilibre et donc là on a
peut-être des inquiétudes à avoir sur
l'année 2023
il y a de moins en moins d'agriculteurs
en France c'est une tendance
c'est une tendance
et surtout c'est l'avenir qui est très
angoissant près de la moitié des
agriculteurs des chefs d'exploitation
vont prendre de leur retraite dans les
10 ans qui viennent donc ça va être l'un
des très grands défis et je parle pas du
long terme là je suis dans des deux ou
trois années à venir pour recruter ce
personnel agricole alors ce soit à la
fois des chefs d'exploitation donc là il
faudra repenser mais c'est d'ailleurs ce
sera l'objet de de la future loi
d'orientation agricole mais
imaginez des systèmes j'ai pas de
portage financiers ou du foncier ou du
capital pour permettre aux jeunes chefs
d'exploitation de de pas s'endetter à
millions et finalement remboursé au
seuil de leur retraite pour pouvoir les
convaincre d'embrasser ce métier et
aussi sur le salariat agricole parce que
je doute qu'on puisse remplacer
l'intégralité de
ces exploitants donc on va sans doute
aussi assister à un mouvement de
peut-être de concentration de
d'associations en tout cas le paysage
agricole
assez fragmenté familiale qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui va nécessairement évoluer je
pense pas qu'on en arrivera à des
modèles tels que l'Europe de l'Est avec
des fermes géantes mais il va falloir
qu'il y ait une évolution en
accompagnement en tout cas pour
convaincre c'est la jeunesse d'embrasser
ses métiers on peut tirer push avec de
moins agriculteurs produire plus pour 67
millions de Français c'est ce qu'on fait
depuis des décennies cette évolution là
avant l'impact que vous aviez un
agriculteur qui pouvait nourrir 5
personnes avec la pack on a un seul
agriculteur vous pouvez en ouvrir 25
donc les gains de productivité qui ont
été dégagées de cette restructuration
cette modernisation de l'agriculture ont
apporté la preuve qu'on pouvait le faire
et ce qui est posé la les mêmes en
faisant basculer je sais plus quel si
vous donnez 20-25% vers le bio
ah là la difficulté va se poser parce
que les rendements sont quand même bien
plus faibles en gros et la main d'oeuvre
c'est bien plus faible en bio que en
conventionnel donc on a là une
problématique il va falloir examiner de
près d'autant plus que la situation de
l'agriculture biologique aujourd'hui est
quand même dans une sérieuse difficulté
on est en surcapacité et il y a une
demande qui n'absor pas la production de
de produits bio notamment en fruits et
légumes mais aussi en viande notamment
mais là ce qui est intéressant c'est que
dans le contexte actuel de pandémie mais
de guerre aussi on se pose la question
de savoir sur cette problématique de
renouvellement des générations si ces
deux événements vont accélérer aggraver
cette tendance baissière des effectifs
d'agriculteurs ou si au contraire à
travers la prise de conscience qu'on a
de la souveraineté ça va provoquer un
choc pour justement rendre attractif le
métier d'agriculteur alors vous évoquez
tout à l'heure Sébastien bis la
évidemment la question des céréales
c'est le thème centrale de votre livre
La la politique du blé qui est publié
chez Armand Colin je vous propose de
donner la parole grâce à Quentin Calmet
qui voilà se promène dans les allées du
Salon international de l'agriculture
au président de la coopérative
céréalière accès réelle il s'appelle
François Loiseau Quentin il est avec
vous je me trouvais que Jean-François
Loiseau bonjour Jean-François vous êtes
le président inter céréales qui regroupe
tous les acteurs de la filière des
céréales en France souvenons-nous il y a
un an on était ensemble sur ce même
stand et on était au lendemain du
déclenchement de la guerre en Ukraine
par la Russie et on se disait déjà que
ça allait être des bouleversements dans
toutes les filières du secteur un an
plus tard quel est le bilan que vous
tirez vous de cette guerre alors un an
plus tard c'est finalement l'Ukraine un
pays qui représente quand même toujours
un potentiel de production de céréales
et de et de fournitures de cercles pour
beaucoup de pays et malheureusement ces
pays-là depuis un an ont eu énormément
de difficultés pour s'approvisionner en
partie ils sont venus chez nous en
France grâce un peu à la dynamique de la
filière céréalière des moteur des
collecteurs et des exportateurs et c'est
pour cela que la France est dans un dans
une situation où elle doit maintenir son
potentiel de production pour au
rendez-vous de ses clients et un taux un
prix qui grimpe ça a pu profiter au
producteurs de céréales en France c'est
pris qui grimpent alors il faut dire
quand même que le prix avant la guerre
était un prix qui ne rémunirait pas
suffisamment les producteurs faut
regarder un petit peu ce qui se passait
et c'est vrai que au cours du mois de
juin juillet-août de ces trois mois le
prix du blé a beaucoup monté mais il a
il a monté pour redescendre après
derrière je dirais à des niveaux à peu
près équilibrés en matière de demande
donc oui certains agriculteurs en ont
profité mais ce n'est pas le prix le
plus haut qui fait je dirais le revenu
agricole de la ferme France on a vu
aussi le contexte de l'inflation
notamment sur l'énergie ça ça a pu aussi
toucher vos producteurs est-ce que vous
avez vu comme cela l'inflation perturbée
aussi beaucoup de vos acteurs alors ça
c'est un vrai sujet parce que en fait il
y a eu la cause de la réflexion certains
produits agricoles je pense notamment
produits oléagineux les huiles il y a eu
aussi des problèmes liés à l'énergie le
gaz puisque nous étions très dépendants
et cela a entraîné de l'inflation forte
sur les intrants agricoles et donc
c'était très pénalisant pour toute la
filière les agriculteurs les
transformateurs je pense notamment au
meunier aux amis de nier au malteur le
prix d'énergie extrêmement élevé et il
est vrai que certains produits
alimentaires ont vu ont été augmentés
parce qu'il fallait bien traduire
transmettre la hausse des coûts qu'il y
avait de la part de tous les maillons de
la chaîne
François je voudrais qu'on évoque
ensemble la question de la souveraineté
alimentaire on a vu le prénom République
qui en a fait un des grands thèmes de
son déplacement samedi lui il fixe un
horizon à 2030 pour que sur ces
questions là tout est bien tous les
toutes les filières et prix des
engagements qu'est-ce que ça signifie ça
signifie pour vous ces questions de
souveraineté comment est-ce que vous
voulez traduisez pour votre finir
céréales la souveraineté alimentaire
c'est essentielle et raison d'en parler
moi je dirais c'est à fois de la
souveraineté agricole et alimentaire et
pour cela il faut définir déjà une
vision une stratégie ça ne se décrète
pas la la souveraineté il faut avoir une
une vision un plan d'action avec des
actions courtes court terme et des
actions à moyen terme je prends par
exemple le sujet de la création
variétale qui est essentielle pour se
passer de plus en plus de la chimie en
agriculture et dans et dans nos filières
et bien la création variétale demande
toujours entre 5 et 8 ans voire 9 ans de
travaux si je vraiment le sujet de la
logistique et c'est un sujet d'actualité
la logistique avec le programme de la
SNCF et du et du réseau il va falloir
certainement 10 ans pour remettre sans
mauvais jeu de mots le rail sur la route
c'est à dire être en mesure d'être
efficace donc souveraineté oui décision
politique forte et après application
dans le temps très rapidement il nous
reste quelques secondes il y a aussi
besoin dans le contexte d'une sécheresse
hivernale après une sécheresse estivale
ça ça vous inquiète aussi ce contexte
alors ça c'est un sujet de préoccupation
alors les plantes ne sont pas encore
reparties si vous voulez il faut
attendre le début du printemps mais cela
montre qu'il est très important d'avoir
là aussi un schéma directeur
d'organisation qui intègre tous les
maillons il y a pas que les agriculteurs
merci merci Jean-François pour toutes
ces réactions au micro de Public Sénat
merci Quentin Sébastien bis je voudrais
vous entendre là-dessus parce que les
les routes mondiales des céréales elles
ont évidemment été enfin je dis
évidemment peut-être que vous allez me
contredire mais bouleverser par les
conséquences de du de l'invasion russe
de l'Ukraine c'est pour longtemps
est-ce que c'est irréversible d'une
certaine façon pour l'instant il faut
bien comprendre que si on parle de blé
la planète à voix c'est marcher à blé de
plus en plus russe puisque c'est le seul
pays qui produit de plus en plus et
exporte de plus en plus donc ce premier
exportateur mondial depuis 2016 les deux
plus en plus aujourd'hui même depuis un
an oui même depuis un an parce qu'il a
fait une très grosse récolte en 2022 et
en plus il a il a grignoté pour ne pas
dire agresser le territoire ukrainien il
a récupéré des volumes aussi en Ukraine
depuis 12 mois donc la Russie continue
de russifier le marché mondial du blé en
maïs on a un manque du crâne partiel
puisque l'Ukraine a surtout su exporter
du maïs depuis 12 mois avec ses
corridors maritimés et terrestres et en
maïs la situation elle est encore plus
complexe que dans le cas du blé parce
que le maïs en gros il y a quatre
grandes puissances dans le monde qui en
exporte l'Ukraine et qui exporte du maïs
non OGM et puis l'Argentine le Brésil et
les États-Unis ça veut dire dire aussi
que dans ce schéma céréalier mondial
très peu de pays producteurs très peu de
pays exportateurs mais que ce soit en
maïs en blé toute la planète en consomme
avec une petite nuance pour le blé c'est
que c'est de l'alimentation humaine
directe et qu'évidemment il y a toujours
un peu plus de préoccupations à court
terme sur le blé puisqu'il est
transformé en pain ou en pâte ou le maïs
sert avant tout l'alimentation animale
et donc les étapes et les conséquences
sont plus longues donc finalement
aujourd'hui il faut bien comprendre que
les routes céréales se sont surtout
redessinées avec un aspect sur lequel
j'attire l'attention c'est la nécessité
de protéger les routes commerciales
maritimes on n'a pas conscience que 80%
des flux céréaliers dans le monde se
déroulent sur l'océan et qu'aujourd'hui
prendre la mer c'est prendre beaucoup de
risques et que la nervosité maritime
cette remilitarisation de la mer
nécessite aussi sur le commerce des
céréales d'être dans une vigilance
stratégique quelques minutes
malheureusement ça passe trop vite ce
débat il moins de 5 minutes pour pour
conclure sur ce thème de la souveraineté
alimentaire je vous propose deux
chiffres la place de la France la France
premier producteur agricole européen en
valeur les exploitations agricoles
françaises ont produit 18,4 % de la
production totale européenne c'est un
chiffre qui date de 2020 et la France 6e
exportateur mondial avec 4,5 % de part
de marché je voudrais terminer sur un
cas d'école qui est celui du sucre et
avec un témoignage pour commencer celui
de Frank Sander qui est président de la
Confédération générale des planteurs de
betteraves écouté le
risque aujourd'hui pour le consommateur
il est que la France et l'Union
européenne ont été exportateurs de sucre
je rappelle que l'agriculture française
était l'agriculture la plus sûre au
monde et qu'on est passé en trois ans un
portateur de sucre donc le risque pour
le consommateur pour le sucre qui se
retrouve dans nos assiettes c'est du
sucre qui est importé des pays qui ne
respectent aucune norme de production
avec des produits qui sont interdits
depuis bien bien longtemps dans l'Union
européenne et donc le risque il est là
Thierry push comment on est passé en
trois ans d'exportateur à un portateur
de sucre là on retombe sur votre
problématique de la production qui n'a
pas suivi et aussi par des règlements
européens qui ont fait que on a basculé
dans une situation d'importateur alors
qu'on était exportateurs même si la
France reste avec un sol d'excédentaire
commercial sur le sucre et ça il y a pas
de doute mais sur l'Union européenne ça
fait déjà plusieurs années que à travers
les règlements et les réformes de la
Pâques finalement on est devenu
d'exportateur net un porteur net on
importe énormément de sucre du Brésil
est-ce que Célia alors on parlait dans
notre première partie de la décision de
la Cour de justice européenne sur les
néo
nicotinoïdes j'ai réussi à le à le dire
c'est on se disait est-ce que l'Europe a
choisi d'être enfin qui voulait être
mieux 10 ans sur ces questions là est-ce
qu'elle est-ce qu'elle s'est affaiblie
sur le marché du sucre c'est un peu la
question alors attention l'Europe n'a
pas interdit tous les néonicsinoïdes
seul la France a tout interdit donc là
on est dans un problème typique de
surtransposition il y a un
néonicotinoïde là cet ami Pride qui
reste autorisée au niveau européen et
d'ailleurs nos voisins l'Allemagne la
Belgique ne vont pas se priver pour
enlever ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
avec un mode de pulvérisation
franco-français c'est ça qui est
intéressant parce que on se fait souvent
plaisir en pointant la concurrence
internationale elle est réelle mais la
vraie concurrence la première
concurrence elle est intra-européenne et
là le politique peut quand même agir en
cessant c'est surtransposition
Sébastien biche chez Armand Collin et
Thierry push la pandémie l'agriculture
virus accélérateur de mutation qui est
lui publié aux éditions France agricole
je vous dis à demain pour un nouveau
numéro de sens public merci à toutes les
équipes de Public Sénat qui sont ici au
salon et puis votre prochain rendez-vous
politique dans la matinale Lauriane
mansini reçoit Mickaël Delafosse le
maire socialiste de Montpellier belle
soirée